sur des vannes avec mes copains ça c'est
ça fait partie de la gentillesse de bien
parler par exemple dans je prends je
suis étudiant en 2001 par la prof aux
collègues de bien se comporter quand tu
vas dans les transports tu laisses les
gens sortir tu ne restes pas devant la
porte et gaston oui je pense que nous
avons besoin de gentillesse et de
personnes respectueuses pour fonctionner
en société c'est là pour mes amis pour
ma famille être aux petits soins pour
certaines personnes et puis aider au
maximum comme on peut j'ai donné une
pièce 1
un sdf
le week-end dernier voilà c'est la
dernière chose que j'ai faite quand je
vois des personnes âgées dans les
transports je leur laisse ma place quand
j'ai une place assise juste faire un
sourire parfois ça il ya une journée est
très agréable et doux avec les les
personnes qui nous entourent